So happy because I just got the news
that my most recent pap smear has come back normal.
For me is a huge deal
because I've lived with the cervical dysplasia type of
HPV for almost 20 years.
In those 20 years,
I have gone through the roller coaster of normal,
abnormal, normal,
abnormal pap smears.
I've got multiple coposcopies
and even the LEAP procedure.
For many years
I was worried that my once high risk service
call dysplasia might develop into cervical cancer.
But over the past five years,
my pap smears have come back normal,
which means that my HPV infection is no longer active
and it's no longer
at risk of developing into cervical cancer.
Here are some of the things that I've done to manage,
prevent, and heal my HPV infection.
No. 1 is my diet.
HPV is a virus.
It depends on the health of my immune system,
which is dependent on the health of my gut.
I eat a lot of immune boosting foods
and I avoid any inflammatory foods.
No. 2 is supplements
similar to my diet.
I take immune boosting supplements
and HPV specific supplements like papillax and HCC.
If you wanna learn more about that,
read the caption.
No. 3 is my lifestyle.
I make sure that I'm taking really good care of myself,
getting enough sleep,
and managing my stress.
If you live with HPV,
you'll know that there's no medication to treat it
and invasive procedures like the LEAP,
Procedure doesn't always get rid of it.
If you wanna learn more about how you can manage,
prevent and heal your HPV infections
just like I did,
sign up to my HPV Healing guide,
which will give you all of the information
you need to know about how to manage,
prevent and heal your HPV infections.
What works? Because I've done it,
I've got the results,
and I'm helping so many of my clients who live with HPV
heal their HPV infections, too.